You know,
when,
when I,
well,
I've seen this in,
in debates that I've had publicly where people,
you know,
talk about prejudice and I've pointed out to them that they have prejudicial
attitudes with regards to their sexual preferences because they don't just sleep
with anyone who asks them.
Right?
So it's like,
well,
how's that not a prejudice?
Well of course it's a prejudice.
Well then the question is under what circumstances are prejudice is justifiable.
And that's a conversation we don't like to have because we believe that there
are no circumstances whatsoever under which prejudices is our,
our,
uh,
acceptable.
There's a big difference between prejudice and discrimination.
I think those two get conflated.
Yes,
there is a big difference between prejudice and discrimination and all hopefully
discrimination has to do with,
uh,
setting your standards in relationship to the task at hand,
right?
That,
that's what you'd hope for.
That that's the appropriate form of discrimination.
That's like intelligence.
Sure.
Everything.
It,
everything isn't the same about everything all the time.
So you discriminate,
you rank order things and you need to rank order them even to pursue things that
are valuable.
This is one of the problems with the people who are so anti hierarchy,
like the,
like the radical leftists.
While there shouldn't be hierarchies,
it's like,
okay,
then why do something that that argument is so foolhardy that it's,
it's difficult to take seriously,
but you do have to engage in it.
And I think when you engage in it,
it's really fascinating to watch,
uh,
because there's,
it's like you're playing a game of chess with someone who only has a couple of
pieces.
They have this strong move that they do,
but you've got all these other pieces and you're like,
well,
let's just keep this game going until this comes this a logical conclusion,
which is checkmate.
There's,
there's hierarchies all throughout nature.
It doesn't mean people should,
should suppress people.
It doesn't mean people shouldn't have rights.
It doesn't mean people should enforce themselves or forced themselves on other
folks.
That's not what it means.
It also doesn't mean that the hierarchy's,
especially if they're human hierarchies good,
well or,
or,
or that they're only,
that's right.
Not that they're good necessarily or that they're predicated going power.
Like one of the most pathological elements of the postmodern types,
especially people like Fuko is their insistence that all hierarchical structures
are predicated on power and that there's nothing other than power.
And that's completely preposterous.
I mean,
I use examples of plumbers in my lectures more recently because it's rather
comical.
It's like,
well,
on what basis do you hire a plumber?
So imagine that there's a hierarchy of plumbers ranging from very successful to
very unsuccessful.
Okay.
And you say,
well,
what makes plumbers successful?
Well,
the power,
a theory would,
would imply that there are roving bands of mafioso seal plumbers who like come
pounding on your door at three in the morning and tell you that if you don't get
their particular posy to fix your pipes leaking or not,
that they're going to come and burn down your house.
Of course,
that's completely,
it's completely absurd.
When you go to hire someone like a plumber,
while the first thing you want know his reputation,
can they actually fix a pipe because you actually want your pipe fixed and then
you want to know,
well,
do they deal with you fairly?
And part of what's tangled up in that in all likelihood is do they deal with
their employees fairly because that's going to make their business function
properly.
And so the hierarchy of plumbers,
which is part of the patriarchal tyranny is almost entirely predicated on
competence and almost every enterprise in the west is like that.
Cause I keep wondering,
well where the hell is this patriarchal tyranny?
Like is it massage therapists?
Is it nurses?
Like most nurses are female.
If you get females organized into a hierarchy,
which you do in nursing,
is that all of a sudden,
is that part of the patriarchal tyranny or is it the fact that no,
all those people are women?
Does that mean it's no longer,
while it's still a hierarchy,
is it no longer a tyranny?
Is it no longer patriarchal?
Like is it patriarchal only because there's men in it or is it patriarchal
because it's a hierarchy?
All of this stuff is so incoherent that it just,
all you have to do is think about it [inaudible] and that hasn't been done to
any great degree and it just dissolves in your hands.
That's what I'm saying is that if you're entering into a job straight out of
college,
you leave university and now you're entering into,
you know,
the,
your first year in the workplace.
It's,
it's just a natural fact of life that there's going to be people that are
further ahead in this race than you.
Yeah.
Cause they're better at what they do.
Some of there because more experienced,
more education.
Some of them are more crooked and sneakers as well because the,
but it's the,
it's the agreeing everyone agreeing that this is a game.
Yeah.
This is some sort of a competition.
Yes.
And you're going to have hierarchies and competitions.
You're going to have people who when you're going to have people who do better.
Yes.
No matter what the type.
So that's the fundamental issue.
As soon as you,
so we could look at it this way.
let's assume people have problems,
everybody can agree on that and then we could assume that people would like
solutions to those problems.
So we could agree on that.
Then we could say,
well then if you implement a solution socially,
so with other people,
then you're going to cooperate and compete in relationship to the solution and
that's instantly going to produce a hierarchy because no matter what the problem
is,
some people are going to be better at solving it than others.
And then if you have any sense,
you put the people who are good at solving it at the forefront because then they
solve it faster and cheaper and better,
and then everybody benefits.
But then you get a hierarchy,
right?
The people who solve those problems get financial incentive to stall solve those
problems.
Yes,
and they do.
And they do that because the rest of us are greedy and desperate.
It's like,
you know,
we want the people who are good at solving the problems to keep solving them.
And so what we're trying to do is to reward them so that they'll keep doing it
even if it's difficult to give them some status extraordinarily,
if if necessary.
When you look at the people that are the head of giant industry,
the,
the CEOs of super successful companies,
they're the ones who have the giant yachts and the big houses.
And this is the incentive for people to try to get to that position.
And the idea that there's no incentive and that there should be no incentive,
but yet you're still gonna have all this innovation is ridiculous.
It's not how it works.
It's not how human beings work.
If human beings are going to work really hard,
there has to be some sort of a reward and it can't be an equal.
And then then what you could say like,
so okay,
so the right that that would be roughly speaking a conservative position and
then you can take a left wing position that's reasonable and you can say,
yes,
there are hierarchies,
but we have to stay awake because they can degenerate into power hungry
tyrannize so that it's no longer competence.
It's,
it's political machination and game playing and tyranny that that produced the
positional positional differentiation.
So we got to stay awake to that.
And so we got to criticize the hierarchies.
Not the fact of hierarchy,
but the structure of hierarchy.
So they stay honest.
And then we also have to be careful because when you do set up a hierarchy,
then a lot of people collect at the bottom.
That's the necessary consequence of a few people collecting at the top.
And so then you have to be concerned about those people at the bottom.
And so there's a variety of things that you would do to express that concern is
one,
you might want to have a lot of hierarchies so that people have different
talents,
could play different games and a complex societies pretty good at that.
But you're still gonna have people who stack up at the bottom of all
hierarchies,
right?
And those are going to be people who are sick mentally and physically and maybe
people who are cognitively impaired or you know,
or have experienced some kind of catastrophe in their life.
And then you,
you want to set up your system so that those people don't suffer unduly.
Partly because that's bad in party,
cause that destabilizes your whole society.
And so you could say,
well that's the left's place is to speak for the speak on behalf of the unjustly
dispossessed and the rights position is to stabilize and maintain functional
hierarchies and encourage competition,
encourage competition that's of benefit to the whole and to the individuals
within the competition.
And then the political dialogue is a continual discussion between the left and
the right saying,
well you know,
at this hierarchy is getting a little too steep and a little too rigid and,
and,
and well,
and that's,
for me that's also the fundamental reason for the necessity of free speech.
It's because that's the only way to discuss this.
It is the only,
it's the only way of working it out and it is the case you need,
you're going to produce hierarchies if you're going to pursue things of value,
social,
are you going to pre produce hierarchies and they're necessary and has also,
I have a giant issue with the concept that these things are mutually exclusive,
that you can't have competition and also have a,
a good social environment.
I think that's preposterous idea.
I mean,
one of the things I really like about the psychologist,
Sean Piaget,
who's who I would say the world's foremost expert on games,
is that he did a very careful analysis of say,
competitive games.
Okay,
so let's take hockey or soccer.
It doesn't matter.
Same example.
You say,
well cause people now they have kids play these games and don't keep score.
Which of course the kids keep score because they're not stupid like the adults.
But you know,
while we can't have it be competitive,
okay,
so let's take it apart.
It's like,
well his hockey,
a competitive game or a cooperative game.
Okay,
well,
so first of all,
everyone's trying to do the same thing.
Stats cooperative.
It's not like half the people are playing chess and another,
you know,
a third of them brought a basket ball and two of them are boxing in a coat.
Well sometimes they do in hockey,
boxing in a corner,
but everyone's trying to do the same thing.
So that's cooperative.
Okay.
Everyone plays their position.
That's cooperative.
They all follow the same rules.
That's cooperative,
right?
So,
so there's competition,
but it's nested inside a fundamental structure of cooperation.
And the cooperation is the cooperation is the basis of the game itself.
Let's all arbitrarily agree that it's important to put this black disk in the
net,
which is to get your aim right and then let's cooperate within our teams to do
that because we're going to pass and we're going to,
we're going to pass to each other and we're also going to work so that each of
us is a good player,
but so that we all work for the betterment of our team because we want to win
games across multiple games.
So that's also cooperative.
And then you want to interact with your,
your enemies,
let's say the other team in a way that's indicative of good sportsman ship so
that the entire league can flourish.
And to think of that as competitive is absolutely.
It's so,
um,
I,
there's no other way of describing it than stupid.
That's what it is.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an ignorant unit,
dimensional analysis.
It's put forward by someone who's reflexively opposed to anything that smacks of
competition and who isn't thinking it through at all.
They,
they're denying the benefits of competition and the fact that they reaped those
very benefits of competition by enjoying the products that are created
by these corporations.
Yes,
very hypocritical and well,
that's for sure.
That's called a performative contradiction.
It's like,
well,
I'd like to,
I like to complain about left wing issues on my iPhone.
Right,
exactly.
You know,
it's like,
well,
yeah,
fair enough.
But you know,
you should have a little gratitude for the fact that you've got your iPhone to
complain about and those and those organizations,
so those corporations are unbelievably competitive and then they fall apart
almost instantly when that competition starts start stops being a,
an issue because then there's no constraint on the behavior of the behavior of
the system.
So yes.
And that you know that the issue with men,
I think with young men,
and this is one of the things I've been trying to address is that if your
fundamental presupposition is that our culture is a patriarchal tyranny,
which is an appalling presupposition along with the idea that the best way of
looking at history is that it,
it was the oppression,
the continual oppression of women by men,
which is also something that I regard as Oud.
Absolutely reprehensible doctrine.
Then,
okay,
so it's a patriarchal tyranny,
but that in their defense that did exist,
there has been continual oppression of women.
It's just not the only thing that's happened.
Well,
there's been women that have been revered.
There's been women that have been celebrated.
There's been women that have accomplished
great things,
but there's been a lot of oppression.
So if they concentrate primarily on that oppression and that's their main point
of study and that's the thing they want to talk about all the time.
They kind of have a point in the fact that if you're looking at all the events
that have ever taken place,
there's a significant number of them that have been women being oppressed.
That's a real thing.
I don't know if there's more women who've been oppressed than men who've been
oppressed for a very good point.
So I would say that the entire history of,
I mean you look at it this way,
is that we oppress ourselves personally with our own malevolence and stupidity.
And then we're all oppressed by the kind of the crushing hand of the social
world.
That molds us in one way and not in another.
And then of course,
nature is doing her best all the time to give birth to us,
but also to kill us and take us out.
And so there's this endless,
like there's this endless,
what would you call it?
Vulnerability that characterizes our existence psychologically and socially and
naturally.
And,
and I would say 150 years ago,
that was even more intense than it was now.
You know,
because the typical person in the west lived on less than a dollar a day before
1895 and so the way I think that we should view the history of the world is that
men and women labored under virtually impossible conditions for the entire bulk
of human evolution.
And they did their best to cooperate and to compete,
but to cooperate so that they had some modicum,
some possibility of a modicum of security and satisfaction,
and that that's the right framework.
And then within that,
of course there's power games that are played by people who are corrupt.
Yeah.
Within that as horrible events taking place.
But there's a,
there's a massive amount of hypocritical thinking when you are criticizing the
actions of so many people in and talking about how many people are complicit in
these things while you're carrying around a phone that's made by someone who
gets a dollar a day.
I was talking to a journalist in Slovenia,
uh,
who was a lefty and not a very sophisticated one.
And she was talking about the 1% and I said,
well,
you know that if you make more than $32,000 a year that you're part of the 1%
she said,
well,
what do you mean?
I said,
well,
that's the worldwide statistic.
It's like,
so you're part of the 1% well,
she didn't.
First of all,
she said,
well,
I don't believe that statistic.
And I thought,
well that's fine.
You go look it up yourself.
But what was so interesting was that for her,
that characterization,
w the 1% victimizers was only relevant within the confines of her national
border.
Right?
Soon as I said,
well no,
it's all you have to do is expand that out a little bit and you're the problem
and not the solution then that was,
that was completely untenable for her.
She couldn't include herself in the population of victimizers.
Even though you know she lives in a Western country and she's a well paid
journalist and she's lived a very privileged life,
so to speak,
by historical standards to someone living in the Congo or,
or,
or anybody living anywhere in the entire history of the human race up until,
right.
Yeah,
for sure.
If you make $34,000 today,
you absolutely are in the top 1% of everybody who's ever lived while of course,
of course.
Yes,
he is definitely,
especially given what you can buy with it.
The only reason to deny that is because it doesn't fit what you've come into.
The argument with.
It doesn't,
it doesn't fit your pre the the,
the,
the priest predisposed notion that you have the,
your idea that you're,
it's so rigid.
This idea that you are not one of the ones that it's the same.
That's right.
That's carrying that iPhone with that laptop and all these different things that
you enjoy that are created by these corporations that you,
you support them financially,
but yet they're the ones that are destroying this earth.
These are the ones that you're rallying against these,
the ones that you hate against.
Yeah.
Well,
the victim,
victimizer narrative only works if you assume that you're a victim.
Right?
And as soon as you assume that you're a victimizer,
well then it's not so much fun.
And one of the things I wrote the forward for the new version of,
of soldier Knutson's Gulag archipelago,
the abridged version,
it came out November 1st.